مبادرات نوعيه لتحسين جوده الخدمه
العلاجيه لمرضى السرطان اطلقتها جمعيه
تفاؤل في مدينه الاحساء منها مبادره اي
ترميم وتجميل الصدر وتجميد البويضات
للانجاب بتقنيه اطفال الانابيب للمتعافيات
والمصابات بامراض سرطانيه المزيد مع
للغربه
[موسيقى]
بسبب مرض سرطان الثدي الذي اصيبت به قبل
اكثر من ست سنوات لتزداد متاعبها النفسيه
والمعنويه ساره المتعفيه من المرض تعود من
جديد لتجدد عزتها المجتمعيه في اجراء
عمليتي ترميم وتجميل الصدر وذلك بعد
استئصاله لتصبح اليوم اكثر حضوره وتفاعلا
في المجتمع المستفيده من مبادره ترميم
الثدي من جامعه تفاعل الحمد لله همم
المبادره رجعت لي ثقه نفسي
وسويت العمليه وانا الحمد لله احسن حاجه
الحمد لله
مناسبات التي تعيش للمراه خصوصا ايضا في
العلاقات الزوجيه وخصوص العلاقات الخاصه
لا شك انها لها اثر جدا ممتاز لدى كل شيء
سيده عمليات ترميمي وتجميل الصدر مبادرته
اطلقتها جمعيه تفاؤل لمكافحه السرطان
بالاحساء استهدفت حتى الان 10 مستفيدات
اعاده لهن التفاؤلات والثقه بالنفس فيما
تتاهب الجمعيه لاطلاق مبادره تجميد
البويضات للانجاب بتقنيه اطفال الانابيب
والتي وصل عدد التسجيل فيها الى 30
مستفيده من مصابات بامراض سرطانيه هناك
مبادره
الاولى هي عمليات التجميل او ترميم الصدر
للسيدات والحمد لله الى الان تم بدعم من
جمعيه الاحسان عمليات ننتقل الى اقامه خمس
عمليات للسيدات مصردات من الجميع ايضا
بادره الثانيه هي اطفال الانابيب وايضا
تجميد البويضات تفاؤل قبل ان تبدا السيده
من المراحل العلاجيه بامكان ان تستفيد من
هذه الخدمه
تبنتها تفاؤل لرعايه مرض السرطان عبر
التعزيزي البيئه الرقميه في ضمان جوده
الخدمات المقدمه للمرضى ورفع مستوى الوعي
المجتمعي من خلال التوعيه والكشف المبكر
وصولا الى تقديم خدمات متكامله في الجوانب
النفسيه والعلاجيه وكذلك التعليميه
والمهنيه من الاحساء على اللغب العربيه